تسيطر اوروبا على الكعكه الاكبر من
السياحه وجذبيه مدنها للسياح في عام 2020
وفقا لتقرير صدر عن شركه ابحاث الاسواق
البريطانيه يوروبوليتر قبل نهايه كل عام
يتناول تقريرها لدرجه الجاذبيه 100 مدينه
في جميع انحاء العالم عبر السيتي فيات بما
في ذلك الاداء السياحي والبنيه التحتيه
والصحه والسلامه
للمره الثانيه على التوالي بسبب ادائها
السياحي الاستثنائي لهذا العام
اما اماره دبي الاماراتيه تاتي في المرتبه
الثانيه بالقائمه حيث وصلت اكثر من 12
مليون رحله دوليه الى البلاد وهو نحو ضعف
ما كان عليه الوضع في العام الماضي
امستردام ومدريد وروما في المركز الثالث
والرابع والخامس ورغمى الاضطرابات في
بريطانيا الى ان لندن قفزت مرتبتين الى
المركز السادس ميونخ وبرشلونه وبيرلين في
المراكز السابعه والثامنه والتاسعه على
التوالي بينما تزيلت نيويورك الامريكيه
ترتيب افضل عشر مع ذلك يتوقع مؤشر ان
تعافي اسيا مع عوده سفر الدولي سيحدث
تغييرا كبيرا في ترتيب العام المقبل